[Música]
Hola Mi nombre es Ángela Gómez y les doy
la bienvenida a ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 este episodio es
un saludo especial para los cuerpos
menstruantes que merecemos Libertad para
sangrar mientras las protecciones
higiénicas lo intentan todo para
invisibilizar la regla el frivding puede
ser un sinónimo de libertad y de
empoderamiento para menstruar a nuestro
ritmo Comencemos con un reporte sobre
este tema preparado por Gabriel colchón
en la redacción de France 24
es una práctica que probablemente
siempre ha existido pero ahora se conoce
bajo el nombre free blinding o el
sangrado libre las mujeres que lo
practican no usan protección durante su
menstruación ni toalla ni copa ni
tampones unas eligen dejar la sangre y
bajar naturalmente y montar su ropa
interior pero muchas otras entrenan su
cuerpo con ejercicios del suelo pélvico
para contener la sangre hasta llegar al
baño muchas de las mujeres que deciden
practicar el free blinding lo describen
como liberador primero porque es una
forma de luchar contra la visión de la
menstruación como algo sucio que debería
ser escondido o contra la vergüenza de
manchar su ropa después porque las
protecciones
íntimas tienen un coste importante y
porque la pobreza menstrual afecta a
mujeres en todo el mundo un estudio
realizado en 2021 en Estados Unidos por
el centro médico Boston da cuenta de
cifras preocupantes sobre mujeres que
carecen de acceso a productos
menstruales en nuestra muestra el 14,2%
de las mujeres había experimentado
pobreza menstrual alguna vez en 2020
además un 10% la experimentaba todos los
meses según el Banco Mundial al menos
500 millones de mujeres no tienen acceso
a productos o instalaciones adecuadas
cuando tienen su regla finalmente el
Friv Legend permite evitar el uso de
productos nefastos tanto para el cuerpo
como para el medio ambiente las toallas
y tampones contienen productos químicos
con efectos carcinógenos o considerados
disruptores endocrinos además suprime el
riesgo de hecho que tóxico una grave
Aunque poco común enfermedad infecciosa
aguda que puede aparecer cuando una
protección periódica se ha quedado
demasiado tiempo dentro de la vagina
y la conversación sobre este tema
apasionante es desde Barcelona España
con Leticia Chamorro ella es creadora de
vaginas libres una guía práctica para
conectar físicamente Y espiritualmente
con la menstruación Leticia bienvenida
ella soy
Buenos días desde Barcelona Buenas
tardes
pues Leticia es un gusto hablar con
usted y quisiera comenzar ahondando en
los temas y que ya veníamos mencionando
en el reporte porque decimos que el no
es necesariamente una práctica nueva lo
que sí le falta es más reconocimiento y
más masificación Usted qué opina
y opino que sobre todo lo que hace falta
es un estudio un estudio real de Cómo se
da el sangrado libre porque el tema es
la menstruación no ha sido estudiada
durante muchísimas generaciones entonces
Hemos llegado a un punto en el que el
sangrado libre es un gran ignorado no no
se sabe sobre él es una gran incógnita
la que tiene luego también me parece
súper importante nombrar como la pobreza
menstrual no solamente alude al tema de
económico sino que también alude al tema
de no tener acceso a baños limpios y
seguros y sobre todo a la educación
menstrual a no tener un acceso a esa
educación menstrual que todas y todos
necesitamos Claro pero porque se habla
de que esto es algo que finalmente las
mujeres hemos hecho a lo largo de la
historia y no es algo que viene de hace
algunos años es decir no toda la vida
existieron los productos menstruales que
hoy con algo de capacidad económica las
mujeres pueden o podemos adquirir
porque es una cosa de anatomía nuestro
cuerpo está preparado para menstruar
nace preparado para menstruar y está
diseñado tiene una serie de alertas y
sensaciones que las escuchamos podemos
llegar a descargar Nuestra sangre donde
decidimos o sea es decir podemos estamos
diseñadas para menstrual Pro activamente
en vez de dejar que caiga pasivamente
sobre un producto menstrual Bueno pues
hablemos sobre eso sobre Cómo podemos
aprender a conocer esas señales o esas
alertas que nos da nuestro cuerpo para
evacuar la menstruación a voluntad por
ejemplo que es una de las maneras en las
que se puede ejercer este
sangrado libre
Mira es muy sencillo nuestro útero está
preparado durante la menstruación
recibe una serie de contracciones
uterinas verdad estas contracciones
uterinas lo que nos ayudan es a
descargar la sangre la pared del
endometrio
progresivamente no cae toda de golpe
Entonces esto nos permite que si vamos
desarrollando esa sensación de cuando va
cayendo mi sangre puedo llegar a
descargarla ayudada de los ejercicios de
suelo pélvico en el baño además hay algo
que es muy curioso por ejemplo el cérvix
que es un gran olvidado también no el
cérvix hace como las veces de esfínter
tiene una serie de sacos alrededor que
lo que hacen estos sacos es llegar a
naturalmente hasta 7 mililitros de
sangre que si tú hoy utilizas una copa
estamos hablando de la mitad de una copa
menstrual de acuerdo Entonces nuestro
cuerpo ya está preparado ya está
diseñado para esta sangre
Finalmente y luego va cayendo poco a
poco y atentas porque aquí tenemos todas
la imagen mental de que Nuestra sangre
cae en cascada libre no hacia nuestra
vulva pero en realidad Va cayendo muy
poco a poco soportada por los Anillos
vaginales que estos anillos lo que hacen
es retrasar la caída de la sangre afuera
del cuerpo Entonces si conseguimos
despertar Escuchar estas señales podemos
ir al baño a descargar Nuestra sangre
esto es como con la orina con la orina
al principio no sabíamos cuánto podíamos
retrasar el ir al baño Bueno pues con la
sangre poco a poco podemos ir trabajando
para saber hasta qué punto yo puedo
retrasar mi visita al baño Leticia por
favor cuéntenos un poco de cómo ha sido
su propia experiencia o su propio
entrenamiento para tener un suelo
pélvico fuerte y poder manejar la
menstruación Pues casi que a voluntad no
O más bien a voluntad de nuestro cuerpo
exactamente a voluntad de nuestro cuerpo
muy buena bueno Yo es que empecé sin
saber fue mucha intuición Yo hace casi
10 años empecé Bueno un día en mi casa
había leído un artículo sobre una mujer
que había perdido una pierna por el
causa de uso de un tampón y aquello Me
dejó en total shock y dije No puede ser
que un producto que utilizo Normalmente
me pueda llegar a matar entonces a
partir de ese momento empecé a
investigar no a ver qué es lo que la
menstruación a ver qué es lo que pasaba
mi cuerpo y me di cuenta uno el primer
día que empecé a practicarlo me di
cuenta de que en unas veces que puedo ir
al baño
hice un par de ejercicios de suelo
pélvico con traje y relajé no los
músculos de mi cavidad pélvica Y
entonces cayó una gota de sangre y pensé
acabó de menstruar voluntariamente Wow
Me quedé fascinada entonces dije si lo
puedo hacer en este momento lo puedo
hacer durante toda mi menstruación Y así
fue empecé a analizar a investigar y
desde entonces no me he vuelto a poner
ni un tampón ni una compresa ni una copa
porque soy completamente consciente de
cuando mi cuerpo necesita menstruar
bueno esa es una parte y digamos que
obedecería no manchar durante la
menstruación sino hacer una evacuación
en el baño pero hay otra parte muy
hermosa del y es la libertad para poder
sangrar para poder manchar sin que esto
sea objeto de un tabú Y esto es casi que
una Revolución contra la
heteronormatividad hablemos un poco de
eso y de cómo también me protege nuestro
cuerpo no de productos que
potencialmente podrían ser dañinos
Sí desde luego Es realmente es una
reivindicación es una protesta total a
esa oscuridad ese tabú que ha estado
siempre envolviendo la menstruación No
eso que teníamos que siempre estar como
avergonzadas cuando en realidad es lo
más natural que podemos tener en el
cuerpo o no Entonces es esa
reivindicación que nos iba a decir si yo
quiero menstruar y quiero que mi sangre
pase a mis pantalones desde luego
vayamos a hacerlo Yo además me gusta
también llevarlo a un nivel más allá
porque de vez en cuando me suelo pasear
Por las calles de diferentes ciudades
del mundo con unos pantalones con sangre
menstrual sobre todo reivindicando que
menstruamos con miedo que ya está bien
de menstruar con miedo a que Nuestra
sangre pase el pantalón que está bien si
pasa Bueno pues ha pasado no pero sobre
todo el saber que podemos menstruar
libremente que no tenemos que estar
esclavas de
nuestra menstruación
Hay algo que me llama mucho la atención
Leticia es que usted habla también de
una conexión espiritual con nuestra
menstruación y dicho eso la percibimos
culturalmente como un desecho pero no
necesariamente tiene que ser la
menstruación vista de esa manera sino
más bien como un fluido que no solo es
vital sino que puede ser dador o de vida
o un aporte para la vida incluso
desde luego Es más hace un tiempo una
universidad de Wichita lo que hizo es
recoger una cantidad muy pequeña creo
que fueron como 5 mililitros de sangre
de una mujer sana en periodo fértil y lo
que hicieron fue desarrollar esas
células madres que contiene la
menstruación y consiguieron desarrollar
en tan solo unas semanas células del
corazón
entonces con esto de qué es lo que
quiero decir que la sangre no es sucia
primero que segundo tiene una serie de
componentes que lo que están lo que
estaban preparados para albergar vida
con lo cual la sangre es vida entonces
dejemos de tratarla con ese punto de
suciedad de miedo de vergüenza porque en
realidad esta sangre es vida
bueno Y ya que se nos va acabando el
tiempo yo simplemente quisiera pedirle a
usted Leticia que hiciera un llamado
para los cuerpos menstruantes porque
estamos adaptados a utilizar toallas
higiénicas con algodones transgénicos o
copas semestrales que están hechas de
materiales de plásticos etc etc etc que
no solo contaminan sino que nos
contaminan nuestro cuerpo por qué qué es
lo que usted ha encontrado en la
diferencia entre usar productos y no
usarlos
Yo siempre digo una cosa qué es lo que
quieres meter dentro de tu vagina Tú
crees que tu vagina se merece que le
introduzcas una serie de componentes
tóxicos crees que tu vagina está
deseando que tú le introduzcas algo
cuando en realidad
tu vagina puede menstruar sola entonces
yo lo que me he dado cuenta Es que desde
que dejé de utilizar todos estos tipos
de productos mi cuerpo menstúa
completamente distinto la sangre es
mucho más roja y además es una sensación
de completo empoderamiento el saber que
no necesito absolutamente nada Y menos
cosas productos que me pueden dañar para
poder menstruar en libertad pues
finalmente para poder menstruar en
libertad de Leticia dónde podríamos las
mujeres que queremos aprender más sobre
este tema ir a buscar información o ir a
buscar entrenamiento para empoderarnos
de nuestro cuerpo
Bueno yo lo que hice fue escribir un
libro que se llamaba ginas libres que lo
tengo justo aquí que es una guía
práctica que lo que hago es acompañar a
todas aquellas mujeres a que todas
aquellas personas menstruantes que
quieren realmente alcanzar el sangrado
libre pero no saben cómo hacerlo a
conseguirlo no como paso a paso voy
dando ejercicios y actividades para
poder conectar con la menstruación y
para poder entender cómo se menstúa pero
más allá del libro también doy muchas
claves en mis en mi página de Instagram
y desde luego si a día de hoy lo bueno
que tenemos de Google es que si
tecleamos en Google sangrado libre
aparece muchísima información súper
valiosa noticia Muchísimas gracias a
usted ya llegamos al final del programa
Pero gracias por los conceptos que nos
da
Muchísimas gracias a vosotros por
haberme acogido en vuestro programa no y
por supuesto que la sangre menstrual no
da pena Muchas gracias a usted Gracias a
nuestros televidentes nos vemos
Próximamente en ellas hoy y en France 24
[Música]